[Music]
we are very excited about our next guest
singer rapper and actor queen latifah
she burst onto the scene in the 1980s
with her debut hit album all hell the
queen and she has transformed the
entertainment industry ever since the
grammy emmy in golden globe winner has
starred in hit shows in movies like
living single girls trip last holiday in
chicago in the cbs series the equalizer
she plays a vigilante named robin mccall
in this clip her character meets with a
man who's been having visions about his
missing sister
so you think someone's trying to kill
her yes
man with a scar on his face
you know nope
well why do you think he's out there i
don't know
what does his sister say why does it
matter what she said
she's out there
she could be dead all right
i'm just looking for something to go on
when is the last time you spoke to your
sister that doesn't matter
it matters if you want my help
a year ago
a year ago so how could you possibly
know she's in trouble
because i see things
visions hip-hop royalty just walked in
an icon just walked in
that is right just sauntered in there
he's also executive producer of the
equalizer good morning how are you doing
queen i'm good i'm blessed to one of the
one of the many executive producers so
i'm happy to be here how y'all doing
good morning good morning we're happy
that morning world we're talking about
the world you know speaking of the
equalizer this show touches on very
timely issues um asian hate crimes
immigration the list goes on and on and
on why did you feel like it's important
to tackle some of these topics on this
show
it's the equalizer you know it's really
about tackling those topics um
you know i was a fan of the show as a
kid
uh and i'm obviously a fan of denzel's
movies of course
but for this version from a version for
me for queen latifah
a mom
who is in this business
disillusioned by by her
the company if you will that she worked
for
um
she wanted to use her skills for
the everyman if you will
or every woman or everything you know
yeah and so um
for me uh for us it was important to to
take uh topics that were ripped from the
headlines
and really deal with them yeah like
we're not afraid to touch anything if
anything holding back on a lot of stuff
so
um there's so many things that you you
all talk about every morning that we
could
make an entire episode uh out of and so
it's important to talk about these
subjects but also to see some justice
met and i think that's what people have
gravitated to it's with the world being
so askew um it is really nice to
see good things happen at the end of the
day and sometimes
bad things happen in the show rough
things happen but
but you see the attempt at
at the at an even uh
yes some equalizing happening it takes
on regular people this is the thing
you are such a badass on and off the
screen but in this role as robin mccall
it's such a physical role yes and i'm
wondering and and i can see a lot of
times you're doing your own stunts how
do you get ready for that because you
are so good at the physicality of it
you know i say what
yeah
is there anything you want i got to do
what you call me what yeah
i know you didn't just
and then i'm ready and then you're right
um no uh but
i think par i think it's a combination
of different things that have happened
in my life my father was a
police officer retired tactical you know
vietnam veteran you seem to know what
you're doing i love that yeah my father
got us ready real early you know what i
mean it was just a normal thing in our
household um
we were big
karate movie fans and so my brother and
i as little kids so every thursday uh
when my father got paid every other
thursday we'd go have dinner at a
chinese restaurant and then we go watch
two uh karate pictures yeah so it was
just like
normal for us to and then of course we
took some karate classes as well so
um i liked it and then we were taught
not to use this none of it yeah not to
use not to use any of that it's very
important to defend someone yes defend
your mom very important or to break you
know for bullies you know to kind of
stop that but not to use any of this i i
like that you play a mother too you have
a teenage daughter in here and that is a
role she's in therapy we get to see a
tender side between the two of you and
then you with your mom in the in the
show as well so i feel we get to see all
sorts of sides of you in this particular
character do you feel that too
i know it's called acting
it is and and it is
but but
but it is a um a meeting of my life as
well as as this uh character's life
which is a lot of fun
um and it's difficult
because it is difficult you know i know
i haven't raised a 16 15 year old yet
but i've been one and i've been that
child um
and
this is part of the reason i am who i am
is because i had to get out here in the
world and see what was going on but
there was a lot of danger so i know
there were times my mother
you know was like praying for me and
yeah we had to have those talks you know
she had to explain things to me and i
had to we had to come to a place where
we trusted one another
and i i could be honest with her about
what was going on in my life and she
could give me the best advice in the
world and i trusted her advice more than
anyone else's right so
but it wasn't easy it had we had to you
know go through some not any of this but
we had to go through some
you know some serious um discussions
yeah
what you're bringing to this role what
you're doing in the role what the show
is doing it's clearly connecting with an
audience because it falls to me to
reveal the happy news yes it's renewed
for not one but two additional seasons i
mean that's congratulations good because
i don't have my drop where's the mic the
golden mic that was supposed to be i'm
pretty sure i ordered a two-year gold
season
that's good high quality you know
as an equalizer
number one scripted series for cbs okay
that's no small feat congratulations
thank you very much and what does it
mean to you to be executive producer too
is it more headache is it more joy is it
more stress for you because in addition
to acting in it and starring in it
you're also the ep
i don't know any different it's normal
for me you know so to to run
a company to be a boss to
you know be in charge of of my
you know decisions in my my career my
life that's been normal you know being a
boss mean you're bringing living single
back bone okay
30 years necessarily say because i
wasn't the executive purdue while i was
a little bit but you know people i think
we should i mean i think it'd be fun we
we talked about a vet and and shot kim
and myself and
and and the rest of the group we've had
conversation about it we love the show
do you want to the world's been waiting
yeah do you want to
if somebody back that brinks truck up
then we can have a discussion okay all
right i know some people that know some
people we can make that happen truck are
we talking you know let's let's start at
at least an 18-foot truck wow good
budget you know then we then we back it
up you know one last thing just quick
response can we get some more music uh
music is there i mean i make music it's
so much music sitting around
uh music is what i do when i get off of
the 12
14-hour day work okay you know so music
is in me and that's part of the rhythm
of this show and while we can learn this
choreography for some of this stuff but
let me give props really quickly to the
stun to marie monroe my stunt uh double
she does
so much i mean i can take a gun and i
can punch and all that stuff but
i'm not flying kicking anybody like that
i got to give her her queen latifah i
could speak for everybody thank you for
your contributions not just to music but
just to the culture and tv and media and
your absolute boss thank you for joining
us yeah i'm so proud you can catch all
new episodes of the equalizer sunday
night at 8 7 central here on cbs and
streaming on paramount plus we'll be
right back